we are so excited to tell you all about
forza horizon 5 hot wheels the first
expansion for forza horizon 5. so mike
let's start with why the team decided to
bring hot wheels to forza horizon 5's
mexico our fans have been telling us for
years about how much they loved forza
horizon 3's hot wheels expansion so
we've been waiting for the right time to
bring everyone another hot wheels
adventure forza horizon 5 presented the
perfect opportunity to bring hot wheels
to life like never before with the power
of the xbox series x and s it really
does sound like the perfect time for
forza horizon and hot wheels so i'm
wondering if you can tell us a little
bit more about what to expect being in
the clouds of mexico this time yes you
travel to the clouds above mexico to
visit the hot wheels park which is
comprised of over 200 kilometers of the
fastest most extreme tracks yet once
there you'll join the hot wheels academy
and set out to take on forza horizon's
most extreme racing yet and prove
yourself a hot wheels legend let's go
as well as the iconic orange hot wheels
track you'll take on new driving
experiences across gravity-defying
magnet tracks as well as ice water flume
and rumble tracks so we spoke loads
about biomes in the build-up to force
horizon 5's launch are we expecting
something similar enforcer item 5 hot
wheels as well yes so we're truly going
to see the power of the xbox series x
and s when we look at ford's horizon 5
hot wheels all new biomes the amount of
detail and diversity that we can pack
into the four new biomes is breathtaking
we have the rugged giants canyon where
you'll hear the growl of your engine
bouncing back off the intricately
detailed rock formations the ice
cauldron where frozen tundra drips into
the glistening molten lava in forest
falls you'll see a tree canopy towering
over epic waterfalls and finally the
visually stunning and exhilarating
horizon nexus where the horizon festival
is suspended among a web of hot wheels
tracks and there's more because new
players can jump into forts horizon 5
hot wheels as early as possible during
the main games initial experience and
how are people going to be able to use
event lab in fort storiz and 5 hot
wheels so in event lab you'll have the
freedom to design build and share using
the new hot wheels creation kit that's
over 80 new track and stump pieces that
instantly snap together thanks to our
new building tools you can then share
your creations with the entire community
for players to discover and play we are
anticipating our community building an
ever evolving catalogue of new player
created hot wheels events that everyone
will enjoy they all sound absolutely
incredible mike but i'm going to ask you
the most important question in the room
can you tell me a bit more about the
cars yes so we have 10 new amazing cars
coming to the pack including
four new hot wheels cars which have been
scaled up to real life proportions we
have the diora ii the bad to the blade
the baja bone shaker and the chevrolet
hot wheels coppo camaro fort horizon 5
hot wheels introduces the most extreme
tracks we've seen yet in forza so we've
added some new extreme track toys and
hyper cars to go with them
i want to call out the hennessey venom
f5 and the mosler mt900 gt3 their speed
is unlike anything we've seen before so
we know forza horizon 5 fans naturally
love co-op so how is that continuing in
hot wheels so in a first for forza you
can join up with your friends and play
from the very start of the experience in
co-op you and your friends will then
take on a new campaign moving your way
up through faster and faster car classes
until you unlock the extreme speed of
x-class and become a hot wheels legend
you can also choose to take on the world
in horizon open or team up with your
friends to take on a team of drivatars
in the horizon tour oh i absolutely love
that final question now though when can
we expect to play yes so forza horizon 5
hot wheels releases on july 19th on xbox
series xls xbox one windows pc and steam
mike thank you so much for joining me
this has been so much fun and i cannot
wait to play
[Music]